food a major blow to oregon restaurants
and bars as the state enters a third
shutdown it's going to take effect today
and it will be the third
indoor dining ban for some major cities
like portland and salem and
bend and eugene forcing recovering
restaurants to shut their doors
yet again to indoor diners jen jacobson
is a mother of three and the owner of
beloved cheesecakes and she joins us
right now
from out in oregon good morning to you
jen
good morning thank you for having me
when you heard the news you must have
thought you got to be kidding me i've
already had to let all my employees go
it's just me and my three kids running
this operation
what are you gonna do um
well i'm gonna keep going and doing what
i can with the
to-go orders and uh trying to survive
that way
i mean that is what it is it's like just
surviving right now
um i do feel like for uh small
businesses you know
governor brown talks about being uh the
un
underrepresented population of people
that she cares for
i mean we have that in common i care for
underrepresented people myself
and i think she's oversaw small business
owners
and especially in the restaurant
industry and we're being
underrepresented right now
yeah and there's a picture of you with
your three children who are helping you
run your your operation by the way we've
got your website we're going to give the
the website in a moment so people if
they would like to get
in fact there it is right there people
would like to help her and her family
out
beloved cheesecakes.com is where you can
go to see what she's selling
and she'll ship it to you just like that
but jen
uh 1200 oregon restaurants have already
permanently gone
out of business and i know you are just
hanging by a thread
and as you look at what the governor is
doing to people
in in the same boat as you you say she
does not have the authority to do what
she's doing
no not at all she doesn't have the
authority um
it goes against her constitutional
rights um
i'm i'm essential i'm a mom
i'm providing for my family i don't know
why there's a target on small businesses
and restaurants when i can go to costco
and get my
groceries for the week for the shop and
be
shoulder shoulder with people it's not
right i
i don't know i feel like we're being a
scapegoat
for the covet spread and i don't
it's not right yeah and and think about
it
what kind of businesses have to get
licensed and approved by the health
department every year
it's restaurants so people in your
business
know how to keep people safe
oh absolutely we sanitized everything i
said that the other day we sanitized
tables chairs
dishes uh silverware everything every
time you have a new customer when you're
at costco
i'm touching things all the time and
that's not getting sanitized
well you don't have any uh diners there
but uh people watching right now
are going to order a cheesecake from
belovedcheesecakes.com
by the way i'm gonna i'm gonna buy one
during the commercial what is the
your favorite best cheesecake uh the
signature one
is our salted caramel i used to donate
to a lot of
auctions that we had and it's gone from
six hundred dollars to
nine hundred and four dollars at
auctions that's amazing it sounds
delicious i'm going to buy one right now
all right
good luck to you jen jacobson uh and
your boys running that operation
beloved cheesecake out in oregon thank
you
thank you good luck thank you and the
phone just rang